all right David first of all I've been
seeing your face all over LA promoting
VidCon so it's great to be here at
VidCon with you now yeah I'm glad we can
connect all right David I've been seeing
your face all over LA promoting VidCon
and now we're here at VidCon it's oh
that's my phone David your God how great
is it to be admin I feel like I'm honest
David I was in your face all over LA
promoted VidCon and now we're here at
VidCon now what a king when I think
we're low to see yourself by the way all
over the city
I don't I've only seen it in one spot
and I have to like drive to find it so I
don't know I know where do you live you
must live in a totally different no I
live around like Burbank studio city
that's where I've been seeing you
although the yes oh I've seen you a few
times she won and that's because you not
only Meghan texted me they're like it's
on this street so I have to drive for
the street I was 45 minutes away
oh no you've been around oh yeah you've
been around and every time I Drive by
into your face it's just a good day oh
it's a good
what's it kind of the vibe been like
here for you I mean you kind of are when
either one of the biggest feature
creators here obviously it's hard to get
to see all the fans but so far what's
your experience been like we got in
yesterday and I was really tired so I
just took a nap and there was hot
cheetos in my hotel room so the
experience has been pretty positive but
no this is kind of like our first like
official day so we haven't done much yet
this is probably like the first we had a
couple meetings is our first stop it's
cool it's really cool to see like
everyone in like one building like
everyone that does the same thing just
like under one like it feels like we're
all in school and we all have to hang
out with each other and the whole
blogspot was in them together her family
don't say that - out - apparently Jonah
wasn't invited I don't know why oh and
he's honest I don't know why Jonah why
aren't you okay so yeah yeah so we had
that panel that'll be a lot of fun
actually like panels a lot so that's
probably my favorite thing to do
yeah and it whenever you guys fix it I
mean what could possibly go wrong you
know I feel very calm really yeah we're
very underwhelming in person house we're
just like hanging out and talking no
one's gonna be like drinking their own
pee or like you know alcohol and yeah
different yeah what you've been so busy
lately I feel like I mean every time I
see you I feel like things just keep
getting bigger and bigger for you and
your career looking back on like this
past year what are you most proud of
because you have the podcast the vlogs
are doing so well we've been with every
celebrity in your videos - oh I just
started a disposable page and I'm
supposable yeah I don't have my camera
with you but it's um yeah I'm taking
pictures I'm disposable it definitely
wasn't my idea but I really like it
I'm having a lot of fun with that cuz I
basically I take pictures on a little
disposable and the pictures turn on
incredible so when they make you look
like a photographer and - it gives me
like another purpose to be at parties
like I hate being at parties but I feel
the need to be there because it work so
now I have like another job where I can
like take pictures with people out
parties so I'm like really enjoying that
that Beyonce thought it was great oh my
yeah great work that was that was
something I was very happy about that
yeah no idea was gonna turn out the way
it did well one thing that I definitely
didn't see coming was you finding love
but also losing it so good Lorraine -
yeah I'm sure it's an emotional time for
you still you know reeling from York
it's crazy because I have for people to
respect my privacy no one responds no no
it was good it was um we had so much fun
like the whole trip was some of it was
it was nice to be married for a little
bit but I realized that it's a lot of
work and I'm not ready for it yet and
what was it like being a father - jason
has a short amount oh yeah he misbehaves
a lot yeah it was a definitely a new
page
gonna have to figure out how to I don't
know it's difficult there's ups and
downs to it but um but I was with the
love of my life so I didn't care but
yeah
did you bestow and like father sent
advice sir Jason oh yeah yeah I taught
him I talked about sexes oh that's great
yeah yeah I would rely on you for sure
for that yeah um now what it's like like
because I did in your recent vlog um you
had who is it Cindy yeah Wolfie Cindy
yes she confessed her question which
I've noticed as a theme and your vlogs
you'd like to get beautiful girls to
confess your feelings so and then you
kind of reject them it's um they're so
it's so crazy because they're so open
about it always especially when the
cameras on they're like they don't care
about talking about it and it's really
funny and they have such a good time
yeah and it's just like that's
definitely not to hurt anybody's
feelings but just like a lot of fun I've
I kind of felt like I am also in that
list of young women who the last
interview I did say that you were my
celebrity cause you did yeah that was
pretty bold what did I say you said why
oh yeah that would be my question now -
yeah like I said it's like you and then
Harry Styles like far far under our
under yeah a hundred percent Harry
Styles is that's like that's I can't
compete
Harold can't compete that he's insane
that's like that is my celebrity crush -
I think well let's say that's how just
know just if anything goes wrong you
know I'll be right here I'll miss you if
it can again next year please yeah same
time next year you also got your son
Jason a new car um yeah ex ex son how do
you even classify that relationship now
well he's still my son
Oh God yet it has he has that change his
attitude at all a little bit towards you
now that you've spoiled him I know I
yeah I got him the car and I noticed the
next day we went out filming he was like
trying like extra hard to get like funny
stuff I thought it was so funny I loved
it because it was like helping me get my
vlog done but like he was like really
going like out there to like make make
things funny I thought I was really
funny no but he's always he always puts
in a hundred and ten percent so if you
really deserve the car so I'm glad he
got it
and he's so so stoked about it so stoked
I just love talking about the nice
things you do for your friends because
it's just the cutest and purest thing in
the world like thanks paying for Erin's
wedding I know it's so cried in that
video that was what I remember when I
when I finished recording it I was like
I have to watch it back on my camera cuz
I was so excited to like see them edit
it I love that that was it's such a cute
moment yeah I have you talked to her at
all about what the wedding is gonna be
because now I feel like you shouldn't
you should be able to get some wedding
plan to happen I want to be on top of
the wedding cake just with the bride and
the groom I want to be there with my
vodcast and you've both you've been
married and divorced so you have the
life experience
I know all about it I know but um she
gave me a plus one which is really Wow
yeah so uh has this person last time I
talked to you you didn't even think you
would get an invite I know okay how
everything's well yeah well I have to
kind of pay my way to get it whatever it
takes yeah and ProjectWise I mean like
it everyone's kind of like watching you
now it's funny because everyone kind of
covers the things that you do when you
get married and divorce like I just see
you everywhere oh cool has it been weird
to kind of see yourself as I'm pretty
much a celebrity now as far as that way
people view you know one yeah the store
all the article is about the marriage
that was crazy i I think I googled it
and there was like ten different the
press I was I picked it up after those
so funny no I mean it's really weird but
it's also just like it just adds to like
every joke so much it's just so great
like to get like coverage on like this
fake you know marriage that we had just
made it so much funnier than me so I
love that cuz I ever put any pressure on
you what I'm knowing that now like not
only do you have your subscribers
watching if it is but it's a lot of the
mainstream celebrities are kind of
picking up yeah your videos know cuz I
feel like I don't know I feel like my
subscribers if I mess up are already
gonna be super hard on me nothing's
gonna be worse than than
you really messed up so I'm already
really careful about what I would I put
out and I have like really good people
around me that say this is way out of
line don't do this don't post this yeah
and have you thought about taking a
break ever because you work a lot I mean
no no but I don't want to sound like
that never I'm the replay I just don't
take a break cuz it's fun it's not like
it doesn't feel like work it's stressful
but it's still like so much fun so
there's no there's no need for a break
if that makes sense so no but I'm not
like you know I'm not Steve Jobs
building a rocket ship like I'm doing
something that okay but like is really
really fun and everybody would love to
do so I'm like really happy to get to it
forget to do that yeah let you go I
wanted to do a celebrity edition of
behind the blog okay because like you've
kind of been friends with everyone since
I've last seen you so obviously we have
to start with Kylie and to be honest
again with this this one is the one that
hurt me because I love you Kylie and I
would have loved to be in your Tesla
being surprised by the two of you I
would have loved to be surprised being
surprised well it's not about you right
now it's about my feelings all right so
here's this clip Kylie's here and
Chloe's not it was so fun I've said this
so many times it was so fun to film with
Kylie especially because she's so much
different than like a regular person her
age she has you know she's 13 cards in
her dresser so it's just like there are
so many jokes to make and so many
opportunity because it she's like a
different person but at the same time
she's so like down-to-earth and she'll
and it was like it was so much fun like
as I was shooting that I was like this
is great
and I loved seeing you and all her
Instagram story is like rollerblading
and stuff like that's always fun oh yeah
I've fallen one yes I'm not get out
rollerblading I've learned that's my job
no pun intended
this is a this is a cute class moment
obviously when Zayn this one yeah this
is a long time yeah that was fun and I
think since this you also crossed paths
with Paris a little bit more right I
have oh my god I don't know how old I
was that I was that like um I was at
Coachella and I don't know Paris but I
walked right by her and I don't know
what got into me but I go I go I love
you so much
and she literally she grandma she goes
thank you so much because the sweetest
thing I've ever seen from a person and
she like thank me for saying that um I
think Zayn I think Saenz even she's DM
Zayn about like going to some parties
and stuff so now they're now they're
pretty close oh my god love that love
that Brazilian all right you and JLo oh
my gosh another classic were you
stressed at all shooting that little bit
with JLo I can associate that was those
I think the first time I've ever I mean
yeah that's the first time I've ever
worked with anybody like I'm JLo there's
Oh scary
so scary you know she's so busy so I
didn't want to waste any lookout I was
so scared they like choose the right
words to say to her because anyone
always any of her times yeah I was super
super nervous but that was a lot of fun
she made it super easy so I was happy
about that and you also had a special
time with Lorraine with JLo so I feel
like yeah yeah we got the surprise
Lorraine with JLo and she she still
talks about that that was great that was
really exciting your relationship was
just so lovely and then this one is yeah
I think this one is like probably the
most iconic
this one's a lot I mean we had less than
four hours to plan a surprise birthday
party for Zayn and that the top of his
wish list was a mechanical bull and a
wedding cake so he had to try our best
we got it yeah that was a lot of so good
I mean I feel like everyone I feel like
it was fun because everyone was involved
so everyone was like all hands on deck
like we went we went to go eat with with
Zayn for his like birthday dinner and I
think like kiya Harry Charlotte and
Kendall and another Charlotte and some
of the girls stayed back and they
literally set up the house while we were
out at dinner and then Jason was
grabbing like the car Natalie was
everybody was involved there's like this
huge like school project that we were
doing just for Zayn so I was like really
fun and I remember when I saw the
thumbnail my subscription I saw it and I
was like it's not Natalie I know yeah we
all yeah everyone thought it was nice so
then when when Kendall appeared in the
video the road oh well that wasn't that
way yeah people compared Natalie the
kind of a lot now it comes tough in and
I think was kind of kind of like the
gateway to you in the car Jenner is it
does she like in car you see the Kylie
is that how it happened cuz it kind of
happened kind of happened first rate
yeah it did I don't know how that
happened it all seems like kind of a
complier I think it was like present
Stas and Kelsey and they knew Kylie I
think it just like going to the same
places and hanging out at the same areas
yeah well it all kind of mixed I can't
wait but they're all a lot of fun I
can't wait to see the blog strong
anything up for the Kardashians so
that's a cross over we deserve yeah I
don't I don't know if we do that show
any justice we'd maybe bring it to the
ground well David thank you so much I
know you're so busy so thank you for
making time yes I really appreciate this
for having me yeah that's on your new
tattoo oh thank you my son is actually
here right now
[Music]
yeah oh you're good son let's talk about
this stand up real quick look at this
how do you even get food space you and
this is crazy coming with coffee can we
get a close-up with right here please
this is all over your new Mert aren't
you supposed to be like promoting if I
were I'm Jason you know my friends
that's why I love this game
his mercy has absolutely nothing to do
with them it looks like this is for like
Cinco de Maya about the more we sell
nobody should be looking at a new tattoo
that's cool thank you merch that has
nothing to do honest thing might as well
just take it
cool thanks for coming um yeah thanks
for having
[Music]